finally a movie where I can screw up
someone else's life and not my own black
mears Bandersnatch is the best
choose-your-own-adventure since be wear
the purple peanut butter but this modern
take provides some twisted psychological
scares and I'm here to decipher every
possible ending as well as provide some
Easter eggs along the way stick around
till the end of this video or I'll
include a link to a map where you can
find out how exactly to get every ending
so put on some tea and get ready to take
the plunge because we have a deadline to
get to the first and easiest ending you
may have encountered occurs roughly 10
minutes in when deciding whether to take
the owner of Tucker softs development
deal if you're a dumb-dumb like me and
clicked except the game was completed in
time for Christmas but due to it being
severely rushed is given a 0 out of 5
stars
Stefan has given up his artistic
integrity in order to make a subpar
product for a big expanding company try
again in essence he's become a sellout
in this distinction between artistic
integrity and the corporate chill is
personified by Colin Rickman and Mohan
tacker respectively
Mohan says of Colin this man could
afford a Lamborghini but still prefers
to roll his own cigarettes for Colin
video game design isn't about the money
it's about the art and just to nail home
this dichotomy guess who makes the
assistant go out and get them pre rolled
cigarettes and a lion bar the greedy CEO
of course happy birthday and the lion
will become synonymous with the packs
demon who will get into a bit more later
the second ending comes after Stefan
agrees to the deal but after weeks of
frustration begins to break down when
his father comes to take him out to the
pub were given the choice of throwing
tea on his computer or shouting at the
dude who just wants to give him a free
meal and since tea and electronics don't
mix his work is destroyed and we're
forced to start over just like Stefan if
you're one of the cool cats who decides
to follow Colin you'll be treated to a
psychedelic scene in which Stefan takes
a drug or is drugged depending on which
one you've chosen and undergoes a
hallucinatory experience the drug itself
has the picture of the lion or PAX demon
who Stefan calls the thief of destiny
he's an enemy in Bandersnatch who
essentially kills you
makes you start over and is referred to
as a demon by the old lady in the Jerome
F Davis documentary Stefan puts on later
the drug also parallels the experience
Aldous Huxley had while writing his book
the doors of perception high on
mescaline which Mohan refers to earlier
on while on this trip Colin tells us
that time is a construct and that there
are many different realities that
intertwine and connect therefore nothing
we do matters and this idea of nothing
we do matter is echoed as well by the
old lady in the documentary if we have
no free will and everything is already
planned out for us who cares if we
become say a murderer it's not our fault
it's already pre-planned and to prove
that none of this matters because there
are multiple realities
Colin dare Stephan to jump over the edge
and if you're like me and chose to go
over well let's just say you get our
third possible ending Stephan goes splat
our fourth ending is much more subdued
after getting back from dr. Haines
Stephan is actually given a few choices
as to what to do with his new medication
one option only available to those who
didn't do the Colin psychedelic trip
storyline is to take the pills if you
choose this you get our fourth ending in
which Stephan completes the game on time
but because the pills have stifled his
creativity the game comes out and is a
dud the reviewer on the show microchip
saying that it was like the Creator was
on autopilot so in this version no one
dies except the metaphorical creative
vision of Stefan in our fifth and
arguably weirdest ending if you answered
that Netflix is controlling Stefan after
he refuses to throw tea on his computer
he'll break down and tell his father
that he needs to see dr. Haynes the
doctor tells him why the hell would you
pick the most boring of endings and to
remedy this asked if we should add more
action and of course we're given only
two options yes or [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
but here's where you can get one of two
different endings if you choose to leap
through the window you'll get stopped by
a crew member on the set of black mare
who tells Stefan that this isn't part of
the script as the character truly has
delved into the madness of this
character and does not know who he is
the movie has become his reality but if
you decide to stay and fight the doctor
Stefan's dad barrels in and after a
swift karate chop or kicked to the balls
whichever you chose you sick bastards
you get the same ending of him being
taken away by his father screaming
hysterically that someone from the
future has been talking to him then
things start to get a little darker if
you chose to kill your father with the
ashtray and bury his body all the
scenarios and in Stefan going to jail
but with little twists in between for
example if you tell Mohan you can make
the deadline Colin shows up and you can
kill him in like the weirdest way
possible because there are multiple
realities he just basically submits now
if you can't make the deadline it's
actually random who shows up you either
get Kitty who asked where Colin is and
the dog eventually digs up his body in
the garden which was alluded to in the
first scene when the father says this
dog will be the death of us or you get
Mohan who is shanked by Stefan off
screen and Colin is arrested for drug
use and if you had the total indecency
to chop up your dad Stefan will at least
have enough time to finish the game and
get it on store shelves in time for
Christmas if you do this the game will
receive a five star rating but will soon
be taken off the shelves when Stefan is
found to have chopped up his dad and is
promptly sent to prison this is my
personal favorite ending because we then
flash forward into the future to find
pearl Rickman Colin and Kitty's daughter
who we saw as a baby now all grown up
and taking on the task of updating
Bandersnatch for TV platforms like
Netflix what we are experienced what
we're watching right now is her work we
are watching Bandersnatch and like its
previous krater it has caused her to go
mad you may have also noticed the
concept drawings of lions in the
background the symbol of the
Bandersnatch while experiencing an error
were given the option for her to throw
tea over the computer or destroy it just
like Stefan was given both of these
options in the show and finally let's
get to the safe and the mysterious
passwords because one of the
leads to a hidden ending although you're
only prompted with two passwords there
are actually four in total two of which
can only be accessed if you visited
Colin's house and completed the
psychedelic storyline
if you chose TOI is your password you'll
get to revisit the flashback scene with
your mom and change the past by putting
your stuffed animal underneath the bed
so that mom won't be late for a train in
the morning thereby missing the train
that will eventually crash and lead to
her death but this can't be a black
mirror episode without some morbid twist
and when his mom asked him if he wants
to go and you say yes which is a new
prompt now you end up on the train only
for that one - crash - so either way it
looks like the ending proves Colin and
the old documentary lady right you can't
change fate it will always find a way to
correct itself but what about the other
passwords for example if you type in pax
you'll be treated to a jump-scare of the
Bandersnatch demon before being awoken
from your nightmare you'll remember pax
is the name of the demon in Bandersnatch
who Stefan calls the thief of destiny
if you chose JFD you'll get another jump
scare but this time by head Decapitator
and Bandersnatch author jerome f davis j
ft of course being his initials and
finally PAC PAC referred to by Collin as
a government conspiracy program called
program and control PAC actually opens
the safe where Stefan finds he's been
part of this government cover-up program
as a test subject for years he's
constantly being watched given doses of
some unknown substances and his
traumatic memories seemed to have been
manufactured in a film studio not to
mention it looks like dr. Haynes has
been on it too the two people Stefan is
trusted most in his life his dad and his
doctor have turned out to be the most
deceptive I hope you stuck around for a
special post-credit scene in which
Stefan puts in a tape entitled
Bandersnatch demo into his cassette
player on it is a bunch of
unintelligible static in high-pitched
ringing and for those of you like Easter
eggs this show has a ton like the
metalhead poster a nod to season four
episode featuring killer robotic dogs
the program nosedive the same title of
seasons 3ds opener starring Bryce Dallas
Howard and Saint junipers the hospital
where Stefan visits dr. Haynes sounds
oddly close
- season three's San Junipero let's not
forget this symbol here a picture of
Jerome F Davis's glyph which he used to
map out Bandersnatch which looks just
like the white bear mass some of the
patrons in season two's white bear
episode would wear dr. Hanes first
initials the letter R and the owner of
season fours black Museum was in our
Haines could they somehow be related in
this paper clip is chock-full of
surprises including an article titled
the love machine referencing a
futuristic love machine like season
fours hang the DJ space fleet the
favorite show of USS callisters meth
daemon and 15 million merits which
references a show called hot shot which
was a show in season 1 in which
contestants would battle it out to gain
their freedom briefly at Tucker Soph we
see a poster for pig in a poke a
reference to season One's national
anthem episode in which the Prime
Minister Michael callow must have sex
with a pig in order to save his daughter
he's also mentioned later in the news
ticker winning a celebrity bake-off
right next to one about a prototype
pollinator drone which was used in
season three's hated in the nation
there's also a reference to Liam Monroe
the character who controlled a cartoon
bear named Waldo who becomes a dictator
in season two's the Waldo moment and
finally a nod to season fours crocodile
when UK police test groundbreaking
memory-recall device which is used by
police investigators to nab suspected
criminals but one of the things I loved
about this episode was its attention to
detail for example depending on which
cereal you chose at the beginning it
will play that cereals commercial later
on when Stefan tries to hook it up to
the VCR I also enjoyed its underlying
discussion of fate versus free will you
have Colin who essentially argues fate
controls our lives therefore nothing
matters well in other hand we have dr.
Haynes who believes there is free will
but nothing we can do to stop the past
or you can take the dark approach of the
documentary lady and say the only thing
that exists is the illusion of free will
black mirror doesn't tell us what to
think about these hefty topics rather
provides different mirrors for which we
can reexamine the world we live in but
if there's anything this episode has
taught us it's that our actions have
consequences and we can go back and
change them but life isn't like Netflix
and it doesn't have a replay button if
only it
that simple I hope you enjoyed this
video and give it a thumbs up I have a
ton of new videos on the horizon so make
sure you're subscribed with the Belon
and I love hearing what types of shows
or movies you'd like me to do next if
you're looking for that link about
getting a specific ending check out my
link below in the description and until
next time remember daddy loves you very
much